well we've entered the sprint to
november
and the angle is back to translate joe
biden's words for you
now on foreign policy biden has tried
mightily to muddy the waters
on his real views and actual record of
supporting wars of preemption
you say that your vote on the iraq war
was based on
the president's bush's representations
that this wasn't about going to war it
was about presenting
a clear at least threat to saddam
hussein
bernie sanders says i saw right through
that can we say that senator sanders
judgment
about that was better than yours
look the reason i voted the way i did
was to try to prevent a war from
happening
oh my god it's just completely false and
anyone who has any momentary memory
of what was happening at the time in
2002 and 2003 knows that
but this is why biden has sought to
capitalize on the now
debunked atlantic magazine smear against
the president despite the fact
that the most incendiary claims in that
piece have been disavowed
by at least 21 current
or former administration sources on the
record by the way
no president has ever talked about our
service men and women in that way
and i sorry if i'm cutting close to
losing my temper
but the simple truth is if that's how
you talk about our veterans
you have no business being president of
the united states of america
period now well the biden campaign
of course is eager to drive a wedge
between president trump
and his most loyal constituencies and he
happily took the assist from atlantic
writer jeffrey goldberg
who used anonymous sources to conjure up
the bogus claim that trump canceled his
visit to an american military seminar
cemetery
in france two years ago because he
didn't believe in honoring fallen heroes
well goldberg went on to claim in a
conversation with senior staff members
on the morning of the scheduled visit
trump said why should i go to that
cemetery it's filled with losers
in a separate conversation on the same
trip trump referred to the more than
1800 marines who lost their lives at
bella wood
as suckers for getting killed well this
isn't the first time
goldberg cited anonymous sources to prop
up a ridiculous claim
or the first time his writing fits
seamlessly
with the pro-war party's agenda now back
in february of 2003 while writing for
the new yorker
goldberg was busy selling the iraq wmd
claim and the idea that saddam hussein
had in some way
aided and abetted al-qaeda he was one of
the most influential journalists in the
united states
whose reporting led to a broad public
acceptance for invading iraq
here is an interview with robert siegel
he did of npr in all of your reporting
uh on
uh al qaeda and iraq what's the
strongest piece of evidence you've seen
of all
that would suggest there really is a
link between the two i would have to say
it's something that
uh i i learned of just recently and and
having this new story
which is that in the mid 90s a a series
of emissaries
went from afghanistan and earlier from
sudan to baghdad
in order to convince the iraqi
intelligence service to provide
al qaeda with chemical weapons training
in afghanistan
according to my sources those emissaries
succeeded and iraqis did in fact help
al qaeda in the teaching of the use of
poison gas
while many of us including this host
took that reporting as gospel
big mistake well at least i did a real
maya culpa and changed my thinking
completely
about these types of pre-emptive wars
specifically those in the middle east
and ended up believing uh that they
would make us weaker
across the board as they did but mr
goldberg did not although years later he
delivered kind of a semi apology for his
role in peddling
this pro-invasion narrative he
nevertheless had
insisted on the dignity of the story
that original story
now the dignity of a story that ended up
supporting a war that cost trillions of
dollars
in the lives of over 4 400 americans
such is the hubris of an unrepentant
liberal interventionist and this brings
us back to joe biden
why did mr goldberg after his huge iraq
war embarrassment
pull a stunt like this in the campaign's
home stretch
to prop up the candidacy of the aging
war hawk himself
jill biden that's why now biden
laughably has tried to claim that
despite having voted for the war he was
like against it almost soon as it
started
well in reality biden was pushing for
military intervention in iraq
five years before the invasion this was
a 1998
foreign relations committee hearing many
of us believe here as long as saddam's
at the helm
there is no reasonable prospect you or
any other inspector is ever going to be
able to
guarantee that we have rooted out root
and branch
the entirety of saddam's program
relative to weapons of mass direct
mass destruction the only way we're
going to get rid of saddam hussein
is we're going to end up having to start
it alone
start it alone and it's going to require
guys like you
in uniform to be back on foot in the
desert taking the son of
the taking saddam down first of all
he's been in politics a long time right
but before biden won the nomination his
record on wars was actually beginning to
catch up to him
salon which is a left-wing anti-trump
website was incredulous that the party
might actually
nominate a warhawk like biden to forget
to go up against trump
who won in part by taking on the war
hawks in his own party
and biden's explanations weren't washing
what biden did was to help ensure war
happened
while trying to wash his hands of
responsibility for it
he helped build the car for bush filled
it up with gas
saw that bush was drunk gave him license
to do what he wanted
eventually biden pretended he was
shocked that the streets were littered
with mangled bodies now the interceptors
is another anti-war
anti-trump site has also called out
biden the democrats in general for
their own long history of supporting
wars of preemption
intoxicated by the maelstrom of crises
both domestic and global
there's been little accounting for these
tragedies the impact of the wars did not
even bear
mention at the democratic national
convention
but in the end a catastrophe of this
scale
can't just be brushed aside
and biden claims that donald trump
has disrespected the troops
a pathetic drive-by smear and a
desperate attempt to cover up
his own lies about his own history of
rubber stamping whatever the
pro-interventionist types
wanted now the military-industrial
complex
was never comfortable with trump despite
the massive increase in spending he
pushed back in 2017
while the neocons and the foreign policy
establishment
seized on goldberg's hit piece they knew
that he asked well what the generals
knew he asked
uncomfortable questions like why are we
still in germany 75 years after world
war ii ended
and why are people more worried about
russia today
than china and why doesn't nato nations
why don't they contribute more for their
own military defense again
well a lot of these war hawks don't like
answering those questions or having him
asked at all and they know
that biden will not ask them won't
demand answers to any of those questions
and that's why they like him simply
stated
biden's a lifetime member of the pro-war
pro-surveillance state crowd in the far
left
epitomized by the squad well they don't
like any of this believe me they don't
like it
but they've it seems they've made an
implicit devil's bargain
that they'll control social policy to
push reparations and court appointments
and abide administration
and then they'll look the other way at
least for now
when it comes to foreign policy but the
rest of us
don't have to make that bargain you know
why because we actually have a candidate
who fights what eisenhower called the
military-industrial complex
a man who seeks to bring our troops home
from
endless unnecessary wars and who
recognizes
that we can't solve all of our problems
by bombing them
if you want to reign in the pentagon
president trump
is the only credible option a vote for
biden
will lead us back to the disastrous
policies that led to the invasion of
iraq in the first place
and that's the angle